hilfe in der not die bundeswehr schickt
ärzte und sanitäter nach portugal um
schwerkranke corona patienten zu
versorgen
neue studie macht hoffnungen der
impfstoff von astrazeneca schützt nicht
nur vor cupid 19 sondern kann offenbar
auch die virus übertragung stoppen und
liga 4 schlägt liga 1 rot-weiß essen
schmeißt auch bayer leverkusen aus dem
dfb pokal
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg unten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen an meiner seite
ist für den sport norbert lehmann
ein charmanter familie es ist ein
zeichen der solidarität soldaten der
bundeswehr sind nach portugal geflogen
um zu helfen kein anderes land in der eu
ist derzeit so stark von der korona
pandemie betroffen
in portugal grassiert die
hochansteckende britische virusvariante
täglich stecken sich im schnitt mehr als
10.000 menschen an bei gerade mal zehn
millionen einwohnern wie sieben tage
inzidenz liegt über 800 und ist damit
zehnmal so hoch wie bei uns
wie dringend die hilfe der bundeswehr
gebraucht wird zeigt thomas walde 26
soldatinnen und soldaten machen sich von
wunstorf auf den weg im gepäck beatmungs
und infusionsgeräte und ein signal in
der korona krise eine nation alleine
eine ein volk alleine kann das nicht
bewältigen wir müssen zusammenstehen ein
zeichen für die europäische solidarität
nachmittag ankunft in lissabon portugals
regierung hatte die hilfe erbeten die
gesundheitsministerin bedankt sich mit
dem deutschen team können wir acht
zusätzliche intensivstation städten
eröffnen
das klingt vielleicht nach wenig hilft
uns aber sehr jedes intensiv bett zählt
weil nahezu alle im land belegt sind
stadt ein eigenes lazarett aufzubauen
sollen die spezialisten der bundeswehr
in einem zivilen krankenhaus in lissabon
eingesetzt werden portugals
gesundheitswesen steht unter extremem
druck seit die infektions und
krankenzahlen stark angestiegen sind das
personal kämpft doppelt vor einigen
tagen hatten wir 70 pfleger zu hause
einige infiziert andere in quarantäne
unser problem ist dass unsere teams sich
quasi teilen und ständig neu
zusammenstellen müssen die
bundeswehrkräfte haben indes selbst noch
keinen vollen schutz gegen das virus sie
sind erst geimpft worden
die zweite impfung soll in den nächsten
wochen
in portugal erfolgen
die korona zahlen bei uns gehen weiter
zurück das robert koch institut meldet
binnen 24 stunden 9700 fünf neue
infektionen und 3500 weniger als
vergangenen mittwoch 9 175 weitere
menschen starben mit dem virus
allerdings lagen heute aus hamburg keine
daten vor
und was tut sich bei den impfungen
mindestens die erste dosis haben
mittlerweile rund zwei millionen
menschen in deutschland bekommen das
sind 2,4 prozent der bevölkerung
vorreiter und schnellstes bundesland ist
mecklenburg vorpommern mit 3,6 prozent
in den pflegeheimen dort sind fast alle
hochbetagten schon geimpft
ab heute können sich über 80-jährige
auch in einigen arztpraxen impfen lassen
susanne seidel über ein bundesweit
einmaliges projekt waltraud vor meister
ist bundesweit eine der ersten die sich
bei ihrem hausarzt in neuburg bei wismar
impfen lassen kann
so müssen sie und ihr mann nicht von
ihrem dorf aus ins zentrale ins zentrum
fahren vertraute umgebung kurze wege
so wird gerade den senioren auf dem land
die impfung gegen korona leicht gemacht
acht hausarztpraxen machen bisher beim
pilotprojekt in nordwestmecklenburg mit
die impfung in der hausarztpraxis halte
ich für unglaublich wichtig und
notwendig die wir hier oben möchte 70
durchimpfungsrate bei den über
80-jährigen das heißt bei allen
patienten haben um diese zu erreichen
müssen das den patienten so einfach wie
möglich machen
hinzu kommen wie in den impfzentren auch
können die praxen wegen des fehlenden
impfstoffes im moment nur wenige
patienten impften
dennoch liegt das land mecklenburg
vorpommern derzeit bundesweit vorne bei
erst und zweitwohnungen dieser dreiklang
vorbereitung gute organische
bereitschaft vor ort zu helfen und große
impfbereitschaft hilft und schnell
voranzukommen unser ganz großes problem
ist dass wir jetzt im februar und im
märz leider nur wenig impfstoff haben
sobald genügend impfstoff da ist soll
das hausarztmodell überall den
mecklenburg vorpommern starten
je mehr menschen geimpft sind bist du
mehr erkenntnisse gibt es über die
wirksamkeit beispiel astrazeneca da
kommen neue daten aus großbritannien der
hersteller meldet sein impfstoff
verhindere in zwei drittel aller fälle
auch die weitergabe des virus von
geimpften an nicht geimpfte und man
könne mit der zweiten impfung gefahrlos
drei monate lang warten mehr dazu hat
andreas statt zehn millionen geimpfte
seit wochen läuft das größte
impfprogramm der britischen geschichte
nun liefert es eine erste antwort auf
eine zentrale frage schützen impfstoffe
nur davor schwer krank zu werden oder
verhindern sie auch dass man andere
ansteckt die entwickler des astra zeneca
impfstoffs von der universität oxford
kommen in einer studie zu einem klaren
ergebnis das allerdings von anderen
wissenschaftlern noch nicht überprüft
wurde
bis zu 67 prozent also zwei von drei
kämpfen können das virus nicht mehr
übertragen
in deren wöchentlichen corona tests
konnte kein virus material nachgewiesen
werden wir sehen dass geimpfte deutlich
weniger corona infektionen aufweisen da
sie nicht infiziert sind können sie
andere auch nicht anstecken was sehr
wichtig ist um die pandemie einzudämmen
eine weitere erkenntnis der studie eine
verschiebung der zweiten impfung sei
unbedenklich
die erstimpfung führe zu einer
wirksamkeit von 76% schütze also fast
acht von zehn geimpften nach drei
monaten ohne zweite dosis bleibt der
schutz genauso hoch um schnell viele
bürger zu schützen bei knappen vorräten
hatte die britische regierung
entschieden die zweite dosis nicht wie
empfohlen drei sondern zwölf wochen
später zu verabreichen was sich als
glücksgriff rauszustellen scheint denn
durch das spätere impfen steige die
wirksamkeit sogar die ergebnisse noch
vorläufig sollten geimpfte tatsächlich
wesentlich weniger ansteckend sein
es wäre ein meilenstein in der pandemie
bekämpfung mehr freiheiten für geimpfte
das strebt die dänische regierung an als
nachweis will sie einen digitalen
impfpass entwickeln
er soll zunächst dienstreisen
erleichtern später möglicherweise auch
den zugang zu geschäften restaurants
oder veranstaltungen und auch in
deutschland wird die frage weiter
diskutiert ob nicht geimpfte künftig
andere regeln gelten sollen
die kanzlerin sagte gestern dazu man
werde vielleicht irgendwann solche
unterschiede machen müssen morgen will
sich der ethikrat dazu äußern
ein großer tickethändler prescht vor
technisch sei man darauf vorbereitet
impfausweise etwa bei konzerten zu
kontrollieren andrea maurer berichtet
für schlagzeilen sorgt heute der
ticketverkäufer cts eventim der wolle
die impfung zur voraussetzung für
konzertbesuche machen heißt es wenn
teamchef schulenberg stellt klar es gehe
allein darum technisch auf das einlesen
von imf ausweisen vorbereitet zu sein
cts eventim will keinen konzertbesuch
abhängig von einer impfung machen
dennoch sind wir als unternehmen
gefordert uns auf politische oder
privatwirtschaftliche lösungen oder
vorgaben vorzubereiten aufsehen auch
gestern als die kanzlerin im hinblick
auf einer zeit in der es ein impfangebot
für alle gibt sagte dann sagen manche
menschen jetzt möchte ich nicht geimpft
werden dann muss man vielleicht schon
solche unterschiede machen und sagen
okay wer das nicht möchte der kann
vielleicht auch bestimmte dinge nicht
machen
das klang nach druck auf nicht geimpfte
der regierungssprecher weiter zurück das
entscheidende ist es bleibt freiwillig
wir hoffen auf eine große beteiligung
und wir haben auch dafür die debatte
stünde aktuell nicht an heißt es doch
auch in der opposition wird sie schon
hitzig geführt es darf auch durch die
hintertür keine impfpflicht geben
das betreibt die spaltung der
gesellschaft in geimpfte und nicht
geimpfte das wahrscheinlich müssen die
die keine gefahr mehr für andere sein
können die jetzt kommt das ist hier
belasten können alle möglichkeiten
wieder haben die das grundgesetzliche
nerven ich kein gastronom nicht mehr
daran hindern ihren betrieb auf zu
machen und ich kann sie auch nicht daran
hindern draußen dran zu schreiben bei
mir nur geimpfte morgen will sich der
ethikrat äußern
er berät die bundesregierung auch in der
frage der rechte von geimpften über
monate haben corona bedingt kanzlerin
und minister präsidenten und
präsidentinnen den kurs vorgegeben
seit einer stunde trifft sich erstmals
wieder der koalitionsausschuss unter
anderem um darüber zu reden wie die
folgen der korona krise abgefedert
werden können
gunter lambert die in berlin welche
vorschläge liegen auf dem tisch
da ist die rollenverteilung fast
klassisch die spd kümmert sich um das
soziale die union kümmert sich um die
wirtschaft die sozialdemokraten hätten
gerne eine neuauflage des kinderbonus
dienst den es letztes jahr schon mal
und hilfe für menschen in grundsicherung
zum beispiel ein crooner zuschuss eine
einmalzahlung die cdu möchte sich darum
kümmern unternehmen zu entlasten durch
einen erweiterten verlust rücken rückt
ragt sie sollen also gewinne aus den
corona jahren besser verrechnen können
mit verlusten entschuldigung andersrum
verluste aus den corona jahren besser
verrechnen können mit gewinnen aus den
vorjahren und die csu möchte gerne
darüber reden die mehrwertsteuersenkung
für die gastronomie noch zu erweitern
also und dieser stelle keine
überraschung auffällig ist eher dass der
mann der heute seinen ersten großen
auftritt als neuer cdu vorsitzender hat
hier nicht mit einem eigenen akzent
auffällt armin laschet hat keine eigenen
forderungen mit in die runde gebracht
ganz kurz noch in welcher atmosphäre
wird da geredet die spd hat ihren
regierungspartner ja für mich deutlich
kritisiert ja und hat dafür von der
union auch schon den vorwurf des
wahlkampfes kassiert weiß das natürlich
entschieden zurück sagt überkritisch es
muss man auch kritisch reden können aber
es würde er wahrscheinlich nicht schaden
wenn sie sich hier ab setzt weil sie
bisher in der regierung noch nicht von
dem krisen bonus profitiert hat sie ist
weiterhin bei 15 prozent in umfragen und
konnte also da kein vertrauensbonus
einkassieren
sie sorgt übrigens nicht alleine für
verstimmung hier markus söder wird heute
aus einem stern interview vorab zitiert
mit einem plädoyer für ein
schwarz-grünes projekt für die zukunft
das hat bei der spd nicht für gute laune
gesorgt also da ist die stimmung etwas
gekränkt sozusagen
danke für diese einschätzung unter berti
fast 59.000 menschen in deutschland sind
bislang an oder mit kubik gestorben
das virus und seine opfer so heißt eine
reportage von zdfzoom heute abend um
viertel vor elf im zdf und schon jetzt
abrufbar in unserer mediathek und in der
zdf- heute- app das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat die rechte
des bundestags eingeschränkt so darf
sich das innenministerium weigern einen
leitenden mitarbeiter des
verfassungsschutzes als zeugen im
sogenannten amri untersuchungsausschuss
zu benennen
das aufklärungsinteresse müsse
ausnahmsweise hinter den belangen des
staatsfonds zurückstehen so die
urteilsbegründung
der ausschuss will die hintergründe des
islamistischen attentats auf dem
berliner weihnachtsmarkt am 19 dezember
2016 aufdecken
damals wurden elf menschen getötet das
deutsche urheberrecht passt nicht mehr
in die digitale welt deswegen hat das
kabinett auf druck der eu eine reform
auf den weg gebracht
internetplattformen wie youtube und
facebook sind damit künftig für alle von
ihren nutzern hochgeladenen inhalte
verantwortlich im sinne des
urheberrechts
sie müssen mit sogenannten upload
filtern dafür sorgen dass geschützte
inhalte blockiert werden
über den umstrittenen gesetzentwurf
matthias kubitz im netz sind es keine
fremden federn mit denen man sich
schmücken kann sondern videoschnipsel
musik oder fotos anderer das neue
urheberrechtsgesetz will das begrenzen
die bundesjustizministerin zu ihrem
entwurf künstlerinnen und künstler
bekommen unmittelbare zahlungsansprüche
gegen die plattformen gleichzeitig
wollen wir die kommunikations und
meinungsfreiheit der nutzerinnen und
nutzer im internet waren
die opposition widerspricht aus dem
gesetzentwurf fehlt ist ein wirklicher
interessen gerechter interessenausgleich
zwischen den urheberinnen und urheber
also den kreativen und den nutzerinnen
und nutzern noch erlaubt sein soll
maximal 15 sekunden von fremden videos
und tönen 160 zeichen text zitat 125
kilobyte große fotos oder grafiken und
prinzipiell weniger als die hälfte des
originals die plattformen sollen dafür
haften und werden deshalb bei verstößen
inhalte wohl automatisch offline stellen
einen aufschrei der jungen gab es
deshalb vor zwei jahren aus angst vor so
genannten upload filtern und zensur
die kritik trotz kompromissen sie ist
nicht verstummt wir befürchten dass
hierbei algorithmische filtersysteme das
internet wie wir es kennen massiv
verändern werden und das massive
auswirkungen auf meinungsfreiheit und
neue ausdrucksformen des netzes mit sich
bringen könnte die verlags und
musikbranche dagegen begrüßt die neuen
regeln grundsätzlich der gesetzentwurf
geht nun an bundesrat und bundestag
seit dem auseinanderbrechen der mitte
links koalition sucht italien eine neue
regierung jetzt soll es mario draghi
richten
der ehemalige chef der europäischen
zentralbank draghi erhielt heute in rom
den auftrag von staatspräsident
materieller ein kabinett aus experten zu
bilden
nach dem treffen kündigte draghi
verhandlungen mit den parteien an
für eine neue regierung brauchte das
vertrauen beider parlamentskammern
das urteil gegen den kreml kritiker
alexej nawalny stößt international auf
deutliche kritik
es sei fernab jeder rechtsstaatlichkeit
sagte etwa bundeskanzlerin merkel
navalny muss mehr als zweieinhalb jahre
in ein straflager
er soll gegen bewährungsauflagen
verstoßen haben gegen das urteil und
gegen präsident putin gingen in russland
erneut tausende auf die straße es gab
wieder viele festnahmen
ach was war das schön als das leben noch
vibrierte als neue leute treffen
umarmungen so selbstverständlich schien
gefühlt so lange schon schwebt das
corona schwert über uns dazu gesellt
sich jetzt noch echtes mistwetter da
muss man schon aufpassen dass die seele
keinen schaden nimmt christoph distel
deutschland im 2
infektionsgefahr und kein besser oder
schöner in sicht stattdessen regen es
für die meisten von uns seit tagen schon
wie fühlt sich das an
also man kommt auf jeden fall mit dem
leben nicht so recht wie er in
vollkommener heiß her
was soll ich sagen ich ein gefängnis ist
ja alles für sie anstrengend und lebe
mein leben weiter wie vorher klebt auf
das zwei mal runtergefahren land manche
fachleute haben da eine welle
psychischer probleme vorhergesagt aber
sie kam nicht entspannt oder nicht die
meisten von uns rund 80 prozent sind
stabil kann man sogar trainieren
ganz wichtig ist er akzeptanz dessen was
gerade passiert die situation zu
anzunehmen weil wenn wir dies nicht tun
und immer nur grübeln dann stagnieren
wir und dann haben wir keine ressourcen
frei und wirklich schöne dinge zu tun
interessant die gefühle zur krise haben
sich offenbar für
oben litten beim ersten shut down noch
viele ganz unmittelbar unter angst und
stress so grassiert jetzt eher ein
diffuses unbehagen mit unsicherheit und
niedergeschlagenheit doch auch hier
gibts gegenmittel etwa sich selber
struktur zu schaffen dem tag struktur zu
schaffen um nicht sozusagen alles so auf
sich zukommen zu lassen und auch die
möglichkeit zu haben wirklich zu agieren
und nicht nur zu reagieren wenn
irgendetwas passiert dass ein wichtiger
teil selbst die kontrolle zu haben und
so banal wie es klingt sport machen
spazieren gehen aktiv suchen was uns
gefällt das kann derzeit den unterschied
machen
manchen hilft sich ja auch die sensation
im dfb-pokal hoffentlich jedenfalls
gestern abend ein echter pokal hammer
rot weiss essen besiegte im achtelfinale
bayer leverkusen mit 2 2 1 der letzte
regionalligist den wettbewerb schlägt
also ein spitzenteam der ersten liga ein
triumphaler abend an der essener
hafenstraße auch für die fans vor dem
stadion in ihrem unbändigen
freudentaumel haben die essener fans die
nacht für momente zum tag gemacht
schließlich ist der fußballgott an die
hafenstraße zurückgekehrt die freude war
natürlich riesengroß
auch bei den jungs in der kabine mit
diesen rot-weißen feier bildern hätte
wohl kaum einer gerechnet
erst recht nicht als bayer leverkusen in
der verlängerung durch leon bailey die
längst verdiente führung gelingt doch
essen kann nur drei minuten später durch
oguzhan kefkir antworten und als rwe
torjäger simon engelmann dann sogar kurz
vor schluss den siegtreffer erzielt
steht ein viertligist im pokal
viertelfinale in dem rot weiss essen in
jedem fall auch wieder heimrecht
genießen darf ja und fast hätte ein
zweitligist den vizemeister rausgeworfen
paderborn fährt nach der knappen 2 3
niederlage gegen dortmund frustriert
nach hause auch mit reichlich wut im
bauch wegen des umstrittenen bvb
siegtreffers es geht um dieses abseits
aus dem erling harland den bvb ins
viertelfinale schießt für den video
assistenten klar schiedsrichter stieler
hatte
auch eine vorherige ballberührung eines
paderborner star genommen
die löst das abseits auf denn ist so
eine knifflige situation ist dann
erwarte ich dass er hingeht und sich das
anguckt für eine faktische entscheidung
ist der gang zum monitor per regel
jedoch nicht vorgesehen
der bvb führt schon nach 16 minuten 2 2
0 durch tore von sharm el santo und gibt
diese führung wieder aus der hand
nach einem anschlusstreffer kann
paderborn in letzter sekunde der
nachspielzeit sogar noch per elfmeter
bisher wo so ausgleichen
in der verlängerung fällt schließlich
harland umstritten ist tot
gelungener auftakt in melbourne das
deutsche team besiegt kanada beim
pick-up mit zwei zu eins mit einem ass
verwandelte alexander zverev seinen
matchball nach 3 stunden spitzentennis
schlägt er den kanadier denis
schapowalow in zwei zu eins setzen ja
und morgen sind alle spiele in melbourne
abgesagt worden auch das wta-turnier
wegen eines corona falls in einem spiel
hatte dankeschön noch die lottozahlen
sie lauten 3 6 10 12 34 47 und die
superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
das wetter bringt im norden neuen
schneefall in der südhälfte sturmböen
wer dazu hat gleich aus dem terry
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute schon mal ein foto vor zehn und
wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder
dabei sind ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
entspannten abend tschüss
ein guter abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter die luftmassengrenze über
deutschland hellt sich nun ungewöhnlich
lang kalte luft nach norden und milde
nach südwesten und eigentlich ist es
hochwinter die kälteste zeit des jahres
und wieder werden bis zu 14 grad im
südwesten deutschlands erreicht dass der
vorhersage film für morgen und sie sehen
hier über nacht fällt schnee und auch
gefrierender regen ist dabei lässt aber
morgen im tagesverlauf nach nach süden
zeigt sich sogar die sonne und in der
nacht also im nordosten viele wort mit
schnee und gefrierendem regen sonst auch
regen nach süden sonst im süden zieht
ein sturmfeld ostwärts und in der nacht
dann allmählich ab und das bei
temperaturen von ein bis minus 1 grad
nach norden und 8 grad im südwesten
deutschlands morgen lassen regen und
schnee most nach im süden kommt die
sonne hervor es wird etwas
aufgelockerter sein und die temperaturen
erreichen 1 bis 2 grad nach nordosten
und 14 grad im südwesten
die kommenden tage am freitag gibt es
regen in der mitte der geht allmählich
im norden schnee über bei minus 1 bis 14
grad oder am samstag kommt schneefall
auf der sich dann weiter ausdehnt
unseren tag müssen wir mit einem
schneesturm rechnen ein schöner abend